hier soir nous recevions à l'ehealth un
jeune sans abri de 19 ans qui s'est
retrouvée à la rue dès son plus jeune
âge j'étais déjà la rue orbe 2019 sur
montpellier restait à peu près deux mois
s'il venait tout d'abord s'exprimer sur
la condition des sdf durant la pandémie
et sur les différentes verbalisation
dont il a été victime pour non port du
masque le jour même où je mets sur mon
poulet je voulais faire la manche a
devant le monoprix et je n'avais pas le
masque d'accord mais ça a été ma
première verbalisation son histoire a
énormément thrill et des spectateurs
il faut savoir que les sans-abri sont au
nombre de trois cent mille en france et
que ce chiffre est en constante
augmentation
j'ai envie d'avoir une vie longue date
comme tout le monde toni brunner
normalement hier soir cyril a voulu
donner un coup de pouce aux jeunes
hommes en lui proposant des rendez vous
professionnels en appelant propositions
de travail alors comment se sont passées
les rendez-vous d'alex il était avec
nous ce soir pour tout nous raconter
[Musique]
alex est là
merci d'être là mon alex et merci à
seabed ma beauté qu'est-ce qui les
bossus life et patron incognito
bon appel aussi sur l'a2 en aura
toujours
est ce qu'ils avaient retenu toi
alalalala savoir que du poisson frais
c'est beau ça ah oui ça mange que des
produits frais c'est pour regarder
chabot ilan épiderme magnifique merci
c'est le patron d'une chaîne de sushis
on parle de planète à lui si ben merci
d'être là en tout cas généraux si bien
que c'est un pote je vous dis voilà je
les adore et c'est un mec qui fait un
travail exceptionnel et d'ailleurs alex
hier alexis hier alex était venu vous
pour voir tes potes je sais alex hier
soir pendant l'émission
on a reçu plein de messages pour toi tu
nous as dit donc que tu est sdf et à 19
ans tu as envie de bosser
alors aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui s'est
passé parce qu'il ya plein de
téléspectateurs qui se demande qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pour toi aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui t'a dormir tranquille
ouais je dormis clair que 38 j'ai dormi
très très bien ah ouais j'ai pris une
douche de sang augmente shirt de 45
minutes sous l'eau chaude je crois que
l'hôtel va ressort une seule facture
et ouais franchement ça m'a fait du bien
de me reposer ce matin ben j'ai eu un
entretien d'embauché avec si à chaque
fois jouer non je vais pas oublier votre
prime si belgrade
il s'est levé l excellence et c'est
qu'on les aime tisci c'est très très
très très très très bien passé d'accord
et on voit les images
alors donc tu as eu un entretien etc si
vaine il y avait aussi une autre
personne
franck bellaïche qui nous avait contacté
aussi pour que tu sois commercial mais
il faut le permis n'a pas le permis
non je vais pas le père de mon bon bah
très bien donc pour l'instant donc
comment ça s'est passé alors l'entretien
moment c'est pas cher l'entretien si
belle écoute assez assez assez émouvant
mais équipes sont pliés en quatre pour
essayer de trouver une solution parce
qu'on a fait ça évidemment à bâtons
rompus entre hier soir et ce matin il
s'est passé plein de trucs pour nous ça
partait d'une bonne intention quand on
l'a vu hier dans ton émission s'est
posée on s'est posés évidemment très
rapidement la question de savoir si si
on pouvait lui venir en aide ou pas la
réponse est évidemment était est arrivé
très rapidement et c'est vrai que ce
matin on a appris en entretien avec le
service rh
c'est un garçon évidemment quand on voit
on a envie de on a envie de l'aider on a
envie de donner un coup de main à 19 ans
c'est pas normal d'être à la rue non
même s'il faut en plus super sympa il à
hilla c'est un garçon qui a de
l'ambition qui a des valeurs
on s'est retrouvé face à finalement à
cette situation on a du trou
des solutions immédiatement et dans les
solutions on a même été jusqu'à essayer
d'emblée dès ce matin décès du trône un
logement pour pouvoir embaucher
rapidement puisque sa problématique pour
venir sur paris
c'est évidemment d'avoir un toit sur la
tête pour pouvoir dormir et donc du coup
on a commencé aujourd'hui à appeler
certaines mairies qu'on connaît pour
pouvoir lui trouver un logement à loyer
dans la restauration je sais que ça te
plaît nasser est content avec grant
je suis chercheur plein d'émotion et je
tenais je tenais vraiment à remercier en
premier lieu l'équipe de touche pas à
mon poste qui a été vraiment présent à
mes côtés du début jusqu'à la fin et qui
sera à même encore présents après le
après après le plateau est un gros merci
si belle demain de me laisser
c'est normal une chance et je tiens
vraiment à dire que tu es vraiment une
personne de sincère et de chaleureux et
franchement je vais pas ouais c'est a
été vraiment sincère et ça m'a vraiment
touché va démarrer quand alex dès que
possible va démarrer quand alors à
tourner avec site on s'est mis on s'est
mis une petite deadline à la fin du mois
le temps de trouver le normand damien
attendre et du fer tous les papiers
hockey organisé tout ça et je pense que
d'ici fin ale fin avril début mai s'est
fait appeler déjà quelques mairies dont
la mairie de puteaux qui est qui reste
pas insensible face à ce genre de
situation ben bravo mais elle a déjà eu
quelques réponses positives donc on va
l'accompagner on va se porter caution
pour qu'il ait son logement parce que
c'est un énorme pas évident et c'est pas
évident d'avoir un logement quand on est
quand on les cantons des sdf donc on va
se porter garant dans un premier temps
le temps avec elle
[Applaudissements]
como avec ça et je suis heureux mon
chéri tu réseau aussi d'apprendre autant
de bonnes nouvelles
ta maman tu le dis j'ai eu ma maman au
téléphone et j'ai eu ma maman au
téléphone
et d'ailleurs je souhaitais vraiment
remercier même malgré tout ce qui peut
se dire sur les réseaux sociaux en ce
moment ma mère a toujours été là a
toujours été présente a toujours été là
et toujours été présente pour moi je
tiens à romain aph à remercier et
remercier toi aussi cyril de m'avoir le
laisser venir sur le plateau et un grand
merci aussi à à rémy aussi gaillard a
gelé en venir à gaillard aussi qui m'a
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup énormément
énormément aidé c'est un peu grâce à lui
à cette heure-ci si je me retrouve là
qui aurait si ces problèmes d'amande
vont être réglé je l'espère fortement
d'allant
on